welcome back a simple but very critical
change in our military policy is saving
American lives on the battlefield that
chain that change might have saved
precious lives on August 6 2011 when the
chopper extortion 17 was shot down
during a firefight in Afghanistan
killing all 38 aboard it was the single
largest loss of American life in the
history of the Navy SEALs the dead
included SEAL Team 6 member Aaron Vaughn
and his parents Karen and Billy Vaughn
believed the military's restrictive
rules of engagement under President
Obama contributed to that travesty they
fought hard to see those rules change
and now that President Trump has done
that they believe those changes are
saving lives and Billy Vaughn joins us
now so Billy the story of your son is
powerful he's an American warrior fought
for our country and from very beginning
you and Karen have been dedicated to
making sure what happened there in that
Valley in Afghanistan doesn't happen
again how critical have changes in the
rules of engagement been to unleashing
our military well first of all thank you
for having me tonight and yes absolutely
after Karen after Aaron was killed and
Karen and I began to find out things and
by the way you know you know us we're
not military experts we're we're parents
who loved our son and loved our country
and our military and after we began to
find out things that happened that night
things that should have happened that
didn't happen we we do believe there are
many things that happen that night if
even just one of them hadn't happened
Aaron and those men may be alive today
and you know President Trump promised he
would change the rules of engagement
Karen actually spoke at the RNC
convention for President Trump and
talked about the rules been gay
engagement needing to be changed and and
both of us talked across the country
about that and we were able to meet with
then candidate Trump and with other gold
star families in and Pete you know this
we've got the most powerful the most
efficient military the world has ever
seen our warfighters can go out and
crush the enemy every single night if
they're allowed to do if they're
unleashed to do what they are trained to
do and
President Obama that just didn't happen
if they are allowed now youyou caveated
yourself saying you're on the military
expert I get that but that it almost
allows you to bring more common sense to
the discussion and and certainly
investment with your son a lot of people
who haven't been in the military they'd
say what are these rules of engagement
what is the rationale for putting
political constraints on warriors on the
battlefield as opposed to unleashing
them especially against a threat like
Isis well okay let me give you for
instance on the night that Aaron was
killed there was no pre assault fire
before the helicopter went in and and
that's one that you don't have to be a
military expert to know watching yes yes
sir and no no and one that wasn't just
an isolated incident the helicopter
pilots when they were when they were
given testimony both of them one of them
said there's a one-in-a-million chance
we can get press alt fire approved the
other one said we never asked escort
because it's never approved any more in
two different testimonies at 200 times
and and that could have saved the war
fighters that night also that night the
a c-130 overhead asking to engage
multiple times any coming combatants on
the ground was not allowed to engage
those enemy combatants with weapons and
it's very likely that one of those enemy
combatants took that chopper down that
night President Trump in August said
that he was going to give more authority
to the war fighters on the ground to to
those people and and and under President
Obama a lot of that authority as you
made an earlier comment tonight was
being was being done by people back in
Washington DC inside the White House who
had never seen that theater of war who
had never been in the battlefield at
night that's right they're buddies with
bullets whizzing by their head that that
makes all the difference
Billy Vaughn and Karen Vaughn thanks for
everything you've done for the war
fighter for your son's sacrifice and
there are 70,000 dead Isis fighters in
the last year and a half at our credit
to the unleashing we have done for our
military Billy well sir you can see
where our military can too